so the question is can you find a man
that can stand next to me and deal with
me yeah but when you say that's your
value to him but who's that yeah for me
i don't i don't know
like when you're selling something she's
talking about cars when you're selling
something it's you you decide the value
of your
fire does yes the market the market does
so so okay that's like me saying okay
i'm nba like an nba why an nba player
would be
stuffy okay stop stop interrupting me
that's that's like me saying that i can
get a top one percent guy so i would say
i deserve a guy that can that can that
makes half a million but none are lying
lining up to buy me then i'm not i'm not
worth that that's your value and so so
you can't just tell men oh i'm still
just as valuable you need to tell
nothing but you just did you just went
off on the right side so i didn't
you just saw it
i think you're not getting my point i'm
gonna repeat i'm gonna repeat clearly so
i know very clearly what i want okay now
as i as you said probably i'm not
available so i don't want to get what i
want cool i stay by my home i don't need
a man like oh i get what i want i guess
i can just say buy my own i don't need a
man i don't ever child i'm like a person
i'm not a baby machine i'm not do you
know what i mean like
that's my values
for what you're saying you don't sound
very happy about that no i just don't
i'm not very happy about how another
other women can think about our body and
our essence
i'm telling you what men want okay but
you can you can think in your way and
that's that's perfect it's not no no no
no no i've talked about i've talked to
thousands of men yeah cool over there
i'm sure men approach her and then she's
saying the value that she brings to the
man that is approaching her whether he
chooses to go to her or on once or 20
whatever obviously he's approached her
so he likes her so that's the value that
she brings that's that's the point but
i'm saying i've never talked about you
guys i don't i don't know about that
we're talking about it
but i mean no no but the question is is
that fair to expect monogamy so i'm
saying over a certain age you're less
valuable to men and then as soon as i
say as soon as i say that you guys get
triggered no no no no no no
and you guys you keep you keep
interrupting me this is this is my this
is this is this is this is my this is
stop this is rude this is my show it's
very rude to interrupt the host okay
like so so sorry like this is
disrespectful sorry carry on and so i'm
saying that if
you're going to men and telling them
what they should value and every time i
say this is what men value you guys you
keep arguing with it then you want to
say well what are my best years this
this this and this i get that but i'm
just saying she asked the question and
said that this girl said she's 30. and
then you said you're 30. so when you get
to that you made it personal about her
but i don't know why no but no
sorry i don't know
his name but yeah she said once she gets
to 35 and then her eggs blah blah blah
she asked her something personal about
her so that's why it got personal
because you made it about honestly
that's why she was talking about herself
and not saying that you expect all men
to accept this value blah blah blah the
point is if a certain man approaches her
and this is the value that she gives or
she brings and the guy doesn't want it
then that's fine you i can understand
that you're saying that this is men want
x y z men want um whatever you said from
a certain age or whatever as if to say
no man approaches a 30 or 35 year old
woman when there's two 30 year old women
sat here who men approach
there's a difference between like force
that like like it doesn't count unless
you get a brain none of it counts yeah
it doesn't yeah it doesn't it doesn't
yeah
you can be approached your number can be
taken your instagram can be got but if
you're not being kept it doesn't matter
you can tell any man i get moved to 10
times a day
cool all right do you have a man no
maybe we don't i remember because we
don't want men like the majority of the
men okay so it's not about you taking
women it's about we like each other we
find genetic match so you cannot talk
about as someone they've been taken by
again so
i learned something today yeah yeah
auntie
we me and auntie had a conversation
auntie explained to me i said are you in
a relationship she said yeah i'm in a
relationship and i said does that so
does that mean you're not part of the 35
and over
leftover women which was a topic that we
were speaking about at the time and she
went
i'm still part of that category and i
said i don't get it like you're in a
relationship you've you've made it and
she went no
i have i've got i haven't got a ring
so i'm still a part of that category and
i didn't get it because i was like
why you're in a committed relationship
you're where you
well actually
i'm in a committing relationship but i'm
a leftover oh i'm a leftover in a
committing relationship that was it
that's what i actually said and even
when you was talking about the value
the difference with now is that
yeah at 25 i was hot
do you know me i was hot slim hot you
still that's
i look hot for somebody of 53.
do you remember i'm fooling myself that
i look as hot as i am at 53 as i did at
25. no i'm just the obsession is that
the same man that i was with at 25 is
the same man that i was with now do you
i mean but other than that no
i don't see that and i'm not fooling
myself to say that you know i mean i was
lucky enough that he had my best years
and he still got my best years and i had
his best years but at the end of the day
i can't turn around and say i'm better
off at anybody else at 53 because
anybody else at 53 must have got a
wedding ring on they'd be married or
something like that by the end of the
day if it weren't for a fluke i'm just
like everybody else
yeah i'm left over
in a committed relationship and that's
what women feel to realize that
yes before you think about
oh i'm gonna be single i'm gonna be this
and i'm gonna be that you gotta fix
yourself you know what
because before i started thinking like
that i was like you know i gotta get my
pension i gotta get my own house i gotta
get the house done in case i'm disabled
i gotta get my will gotta get my lpa
because
just in case you end up on your own
and you know something 32 years and i'm
still got that mindset you know what
because i'm still left over because i've
still got to think like that so i'm
going to fix it myself yeah i've been
with the guy for like 30 something years
i got started i still think like that
you know what because i've got nothing
about you you're doing the right thing
i'm going to fool myself and say i've
got the same worth to him as i was years
ago or i look you know i mean oh yeah
you're a hot come on 53
i think we the goal is marriage then is
that the goal should always be marriage
because that's when you know a guy is
committed to you and that's why i said
you can be a woman for today i was
talking the other week and i was saying
a man could be with you for 30 years 40
years 50 years whatever so there's a
ring and your finger is not committed to
you it can step out so you said you've
been with the same person that you've
been with since you were 25
no before that yeah so since you were
before 25 and did you have kids or no we
got two separate children you've got two
so you've not had kids together now
since since you no we haven't oh okay
that's interesting
and i can go around and say oh yes when
i was 35 i looked really good and we
could try and have children together
come on by the time you're 45. you
picked yourself yeah i could better kill
that 35 of him but then you gotta think
to yourself i know how old am i going to
be when i get the kid goes nursery am i
going to be with
i'm going to go and pick up my grandkids
now i don't want to be going picking up
my child and they're saying who's that
is that your grandma no it's my mommy
and then nowadays you're thinking about
secondary school or university i don't
want to be you know
70 years old and kind of picking up my
child and saying oh yeah graduating and
you're playing with fire because um
the average if you want to freeze your
eggs and go that route like that it
costs like 25 000 there's no guarantee
it'll work the average person can afford
that
now i'm just thinking it's interesting
because you said you were together from
before you were 25 so what like 22 23
about that yeah like 22 23 and then
but you you were in the like you guys
said the best years of your life
whatever and still didn't have kids
still having them
sorry you're still i'm still having that
no no i'm just going by what these are
i'm saying by the way by the worth from
the they said i wouldn't have a child
from 35 onwards so according to a man if
a man wants to have a child in that that
would have been the time to get to have
a child then not like 30 because by the
time 30 comes we like forget it and she
don't make forget it because i'm putting
my body through that by according
according what um
said your name again kb kb
he said especially when a woman has a
child with uh before
that's the best year also because
there's a very strong close relationship
between you know the your your baby uh
dad and yourself right
so but you are actually just showing
that that's not true so yeah because
the difference is
you don't know my story the difference
is is that i had an abusive relationship
that's why i've got no hangouts
completely different if it was a happy
relationship and i had my son and we
left
that'd be different
but i number one i was on contraception
when i had my son so he wasn't planned
and because of that reason that's why i
decided to have one child because i
would say one is a mistake two you can
say is an accident three is careless for
and above your what list
so as far as i'm concerned i had one out
of wedlock and that is it yeah but
anyway you had a child and your partner
evaluate you anyways as a valuable
viable woman so he actually spent after
the best here with you in this scenario
i mean this is
like between that 20 and i'm agreeing
i'm agreeing if i wasn't with him and i
expect what they're trying to say is
that if i'd met him at 30
why should he be faithful to me when
i've given my best years to some other
man if i stayed with my baby father yeah
until i was 30 and then said you know
what i'm gonna get back with the first
one the one i'm with now
why should he be monogamous why should
he stay with me because you have enough
stuff no